[Music]
2020 has been a rough year for many
reasons we are all aware of
and the holiday season brings with it
even more problems
a specific problem a lot of parents
might be having right now is
explaining to their kids why santa isn't
bringing as many gifts as last year
maybe even explaining why santa isn't
bringing any gifts at all
now i would like to give those parents a
break and have that tough conversation
for you
so grab your little ones and sit them in
front of the tv
and let me tell them a little story
[Music]
hello children it's me amber ruffin
i know you've probably had a rough year
school closing not being able to see
all your friends and you've probably
been a really good kid all year
extra good even and you're expecting
santa to reward you big time
well i have some bad news kiddos
do you know who the government is yes
congress the president yes you're
familiar
great so they didn't take coronavirus
seriously so it spread
a lot because of that the government
made everyone stay inside and
they promised to give people money so
they wouldn't be forced to go to work to
simply survive
the government gave some people one
payment of twelve hundred dollars one
time
it wasn't nearly enough people had to go
back to work
including santa because santa didn't get
his stimulus check
and santa has to go to every house no
matter what so
you know what happened santa got
coronavirus
the government let santa catch
coronavirus
and he died the government killed santa
the government killed christmas and you
better believe that no one is more sad
than your parents because
christmas was the one time they actually
got a break and let santa take over
[Music]
so children if you have sadness aim it
at the government
if you have anger aim it at congress
and let's hope that next year enough
people believe in science that
it brings santa back to life now
go hug your mom and dad and tell them
they're doing great
okay bye bye now
now that the kids are away i just want
to say from a non-parent to a parent
you're welcome
[Applause]
you